[Music]
so as everybody knows um it's kind of a
sausage fest so we thought we would
try to
review a fashion from the met gala
from the eyes
of a bunch of dudes in a room that's a
great dress that's the most normal dress
i've seen so far that's a versace that's
a 2021 versace i think she's so badass
the queen by the way if you guys try to
ask me who the [ __ ] these people are i
will kill all of you that's michelle
that's michelle yo that's michelle
yellow i know that's michelle yo but bro
it's gonna get nuts that's actually a
better game we just show steve different
people and we're like who's that steve
she's like
all asians tomorrow never dies
[ __ ] she was great but yo yo
meryl streep that also knows how to do
karate yeah mm-hmm mel streep does
karate dude
also
michelle kind of fine though yeah she's
super find it you ever see tomorrow
event tomorrow yeah [ __ ] it all right
here we go ready all right
ooh russell is that russell westbrook
that's russell westbrook is everyone
dressed he likes wearing dresses no he's
like a monopoly man from the waist up
why the top hat though but he's one of
those blinds
those are the blinds that you get when
you first move in and you don't have
blinds and you go to ikea to get the the
wiggle covers the cheapest ones and he's
wearing some striped socks huh hey
honestly i [ __ ] with the sock the sock
choice with the the left stride i i
[ __ ] the doctor sue [ __ ] i don't like
the hat though the hat got to go
everything else you don't like top hats
yeah you're a doctor what about a beanie
what about a carhartt i actually think
russell's outfit's dope the outfit's
good i think it's good no hat though no
hat you like men in dresses it's
different man it's like a kilt it's like
it's stylish you know i went to a
wedding i had a buddy who got married
and like i guess he had a killton or
whatever and i showed up and i saw him
in a dress and i left if i am wearing a
kilt i'm wearing no underwear that's
what i think because i'm like this is
kind of gross he's probably not wearing
underwear anybody's butt just leaking
out
i'm wearing no underwear because i
believe i should breathe
whoa that's stuff
that's tiana taylor and that one model
right yeah
shannon says she discovered her who
shannon bedroom yeah what do we think of
the outfit what's the thing on her face
it kind of reminds me of pinhead yeah
from hellraising
alopecia right that's what the skin is
called
that is that that's what jada has right
i'm sorry dude lock the door if smith
comes in here i'm gonna be [ __ ] sad
we're talking
yeah he's being scientific about
alopecia he's gonna [ __ ] up all the
comedians alopecia is one of my favorite
rappers by the way his mixtape is really
good he's really good he's getting out
there yo that [ __ ] headwear [ __ ] is
sick though dude is the met gala the
place where you try to have like the
most cutting edge of fashion oh yeah
yeah it's it's it's historically a very
like fashionable you gotta start a
conversation with what you're it's like
the hunger games hang out this ain't
that bad though is there is there like a
theme per year yeah what was that it's
like don't get punched in the face by by
by blue collar america
what's the theme oh [ __ ] i forgot what
it's guilded age yeah it was not gilded
age but it was like gilded glam or
something is that janelle monae who's
that was that jada you told me no
right
he said he's gonna kill us
but i don't really know what janelle
looks like but yes we think of the
outfit this one's pretty this one's
popping
isn't that a chain male for a knight
the medieval thief or like a medieval
nun or something you know
sister sister dude the crusades you guys
feeling crusader crusading
you [ __ ]
who's that oh this is the one that's
under dispute why
that's too far away
is that alicia keys it's alicia keys
that the person that designed this which
is ralph lauren i think stole this from
an asian designer whoa
like they're away or some [ __ ] it's
opposite day because usually you know
it's a lot of asians stealing the
designs
does this look like every [ __ ] dress
or whatever can you zoom back out
it's the city it's the cityscape yeah
it's the cityscape on the cape uh i
didn't see this the city's cape yes
i had the biggest cruise ship
people are like really going off on that
one right now really yeah but i mean who
knows you [ __ ] thief i mean if you
are jacking fashion ideas and putting it
on that guy it is kind of [ __ ] up but
if it was opposite day that would be
interesting to know
it's just their jacket it's all good
they're just jacking it from the wrong
direction basically you can't jack down
i'm a fan uh wait do you guys know what
the matt gallagher jack off it's like a
charity thing i think it's true i think
you paid like 30 grand
and then you get to go to a dinner seat
don't you get invited what do you do you
yeah
is that deontay oh
i wouldn't be able to eat dinner in that
outfit dude i'ma have mustard all over
he definitely looks like the healer in
the larp group
that is a lot that's doctor strange you
guys see rogue one you guys see the guy
dark vader's [ __ ] yelling at the
whole time
he's ripping it i'm over here looks like
lamar odom
goddammit i don't know who that is
[Laughter]
there's something about like the
all-whiteness and it's blending that
almost makes it not stand out in a
certain view cape is interesting though
and it's pretty dope though that's
pretty cool
because it's not it's not all white
pretty good it doesn't necessarily feel
like uh it made a different kind of
noise that's just like catholic priest
white though it's gleaming
a catholic priest i wish they could do a
drunken master when jackie chan ends up
in that old white yeah
and he fights everybody he fights the
chain guy who goes
you like the dress
abraham lincoln and the dress oh russell
westbrook yeah and the dr seuss i think
it's more unique and more fresh like
this one's been done
all right it looks it looks like capes
are in this year all right it looks like
night that's what it looks like moon
night [ __ ] yeah it looks like midnight
yeah it's moon night 100 midnight
oh is that cardi b
what is she wearing one little what is
that one you tell me pal it's confetti i
like the next look like a pinata
confetti dress
that looks kind of normal huh it doesn't
look like it doesn't it doesn't matter
it does look a little tame this year
doesn't seem that like too crazy so far
because that looks like a vma dress i
thought it was a vma or whatever i saw
one of the kardashians where a backwards
baseball cap and a veil have you seen
that one that was supposed to be uh
that's
what is the word like homage to virgil
abloh what the [ __ ] does that mean
he's the guy that passed away he's the
guy that created the uh
homage virgil hablo i don't care i
literally don't know what that means
virgil abloh is a creative designer who
passed away recently who was a creative
director designer of uh legendary
streetwear designer he also created
off-white and he uh he did all the um
created off-white huh yeah he created
off-white that's [ __ ] crazy
okay this beautiful this is crazy the
[ __ ] is that that's some crazy [ __ ] he
looks like a [ __ ] fish in a sea dude
that's gerald level is that not jared
little no everyone's jared let out this
[ __ ] i swear to god i swear to god
half the guys look like this no man
that's a [ __ ] sea an enemy that's
just [ __ ] acupuncture i think it's
some model it's not jared how does he
eat dinner
he looks like a lion fish you know what
i'm talking about
dude how does he sit down i mean how do
you eat dinner how does he get out of a
car this forgot all his nerves activated
with the [ __ ] needles and [ __ ] he's
dry needling around this is like in
maximum overdrive if this church organ
got sentient
this is like a fish and this is like
their defense mechanism
imagine a deal with the tuning fork just
[ __ ] right next to them this whole
body's vibrating is there any video game
characters that you would compare them
to this guy's gills of a fish final
fantasy characters you could compare
them to even final fantasy wouldn't go
this far because this is too much
trouble to render you look like a screen
saver it just makes me want to push all
the needles in just want to push them up
imagine if someone was wearing the grape
outfit
you know like big old balloons
everywhere and stood next to this guy
or what if you just threw a tomato and
it just got stuck he's a skewer yeah he
looks like a comic book villain but i
can't imagine them ever at home he's
hanging out
nobody wants to draw that again for a
second panel no
or a different angle
how do you go to a store and then you
see that suit of needles hanging you're
like that's the wood it's in a store a
retail store it's at the gap he
it's like both spectacular and also like
way too far on like the style over
comfort but you know what
goal achieved yeah goal achievement goal
achieved
is he wearing just underwear because all
i i think he's naked with gray boxers
what you [ __ ] didn't know is he's
actually wearing vaccine needles pieces
oh yeah
that's a statement piece oh that's how
many boosters you need sponsored
72 degrees
69 degrees baby along the coast whatever
but
here you go oh you don't you don't like
this this is not one of your favorites
wow
oh that's kind of a normal one too yeah
who is that she has a nice uh front
because it's just a big old you that
goes
i don't even know who
oh there you go that's a jessica
chastain or something right
we know a lot of celebrities bro we've
been pretty good [ __ ] about we've been
doing pretty good so far who's that is
that jared little
everybody's doing that everyone looks
like jared leto here why is that the
style now his shoes look comfortable
yeah
and i swerve that's what's wow
madonna that's jessica chastain right
yeah it looks cool i think that's
madonna i'm a gentleman that's madonna
i like the matching headpiece you like
it yeah like kind of genie look yeah a
little bit a little bit she looks like
she's going to tail some fortunes yeah
yeah she does so actually
yeah that's pretty good okay
that's cool she looks like cotton candy
is that tessa thompson bro
it almost looks like eighteen
the train
bit
steve is stressed out that's a lot of
dressing up at the bottom
you sit here remember all these names
she's a cotton candy that is cotton
candy
it's got a very classical vibe you like
it i mean your big trains are always
like the statement right for entering
it's very tricky anywhere it's it's
grandeur and it matches like your your
aura right do they have a dress handler
as they walk through yeah they have a
whole team
some people do hopefully they're wearing
a mask but while everyone else does yeah
it's just held by [ __ ] amazon that's
jared leto with russell brand yeah wow
no those are the it's jared leto and
joaquin phoenix from i'm not i'm still
here those are the two twins from matrix
too yeah slice your throat they dyed
their hair it's the watchosky sisters
it's like hey remember them then here's
them now
so who's the needle guy he's that model
girl no
one might told you everybody's jared
leto dude who is that
i mean it's like she just looks dapper
joke this also looks like really sexy
armor the great gatsby era
the dapper dress cool but like again
like after seeing all those crazy shits
it kind of just makes you feel nothing
right yeah feel nothing dang cause the
other one was acupuncture does that make
this down hasn't magnified i mean
because you know that's the assignment
right yeah i'm a fan of her that's
that's pretty yo i like her [ __ ]
shoulder things man she looks like some
[ __ ] um golden uh like what do you
call it like a eagle feathers yeah yeah
she's like a valkyrie from thor yeah it
looks like this is my favorite one so
king arthur and the knights of justice
yo but the guy in the back though that's
like some [ __ ] bull fighter [ __ ] dude
who's that the matador yeah we'll never
know they never got a picture of them i
wanna i want a coat like that do you
would you put tiff in this one
i don't know
i don't think she would wear that i
could actually crush her ass dude yeah
that's too fabulous oh interesting how
the [ __ ] is that who's that is
that [ __ ] looks like a square oh that's
the chick from the uh eternals yeah
she's the shoulder face uh uh crazy
restrictions or the one chick from
return what's her name again god i
should know my age who gives a [ __ ]
let's [ __ ] talk i gotta rip my asian
peeps man start with fashion it looks
like she's she's behind a table and like
selling things yeah
yeah she's like you're gonna do a puppet
show no she's got a puppet show built in
huh yeah she would put some socks on
tell where her waist and how to buy
items from hey i like your outfit it
looks like a real puppet show there
[Laughter]
i mean that's a cool idea for sure yeah
but pop out it looks like uh like like
the beginning of oh at vegas when the
[ __ ] curtain is about to
go into a hot air balloon i like the
utility like some shelving if you need
yeah yeah put your drink right here
yeah
very cool
oh that's your that's just a crop top
yeah that's so normal very simple
anthony who is that
i have no idea is that gwen stefani
that's gwen stefani tell us who it is i
want to say madonna just [ __ ] hates
us for asking everything it's eli roth
it's clean love is important that's
clean but it's not it doesn't look like
met gala like
that
that was actually movies what the [ __ ]
is that chandelier who is that yo she
looks like a [ __ ]
is that laugh dude is that transparent
at her crotch
whoa oh
okay that's interesting
mission accomplished
i think she's a lamp some crotch
curtains i think
oh she's the lamp from uh [ __ ] a
christmas story oh i thought you could
say lumiere from yeah
yeah the live action the only other lamp
man i'm not trying to [ __ ] none of these
girls though
as usual joe's like they're all madonna
he's like put that matador in the back
hell yeah oh there you go
that's the virgil
i didn't know it was a [ __ ] homage to
a magi that changes everything he made
off-wired
and then she has off he's the creative
director for uh louis vuitton right
before he passed away right on
oh mr reynolds oh wait wait there's a
way better picture of her yeah
so she shows up she shows up like that
with that dress and then she actually
drops the waist like [ __ ] hunger game
style and then it turns into this
beautiful blue giant like uh lengthy
train yeah see that's that's what you
want it was like a like you know like
those hologram cards where you see one
character and you flash it the other
yeah i thought that's what happened so
this was fresh blake lively killed that
i think i think this looked good yeah
yeah that's fine
i think i would probably wear some
boring [ __ ] like ryan reynolds yeah oh
yeah you guys the other crazy [ __ ] is
[ __ ] crazy
yeah i'd wear that i would wear what
ryan reynolds wearing but i'll have a uh
area that's cut where my dick is and
that would come out
and put some chain mail that yeah yeah
chainmail's fire that's a that his
statement's cool too because he's like
no it's about my date so he just like
kind of mmm
yeah i like when concord i see joe made
it about his dick see see that's the
difference
there's the bonus material right there
that's what
hatter wouldn't even go up with me
because she's behind the scenes she's
going to make my suit pete davidson
that's it by the way this is the last
one how come kim they're not she usually
makes a statement dude she showed up
last year as a shadow because her point
is that they are the statement yeah oh
there's already so much being said no
matter how they show up
show up in a trash bag
like a whole body was taped up yeah yeah
yeah that was a shadow did kanye come to
this one or was he like they're gonna be
there i'm not going honey connie did
come to this one you didn't see him no
he came with an lcd screen strapped here
with the the ray j kim video oh i'm just
playing the whole [ __ ] time kanye
kanye did show up to megalo one time uh
into just a dickies jacket that was like
40 bucks and that was that was a
statement which it's called
bro
took our idea all right well there it is
we reviewed the who won i got to say
that i really appreciated ryan's fashion
judgment yeah you guys actually know
fashion and i was like oh okay you guys
actually know what you're talking yeah
man i'm really proud of you guys
who won
okay who was the best one [ __ ]
gwyneth paltrow dude whoever's garments
were the most cruelty free
when the patrol the most memorable one
to me was acupuncture boy yeah yeah for
sure that was very lightweight so the
careful boys declare
off jared leto the winner yeah because
that's [ __ ] no that is how you explain
what the met gala is all right fine i
like it i like it he looks like
hellraiser i hated him oh yes
that's what it was i was thinking about
that i was like i see a movie title but
i didn't know what it was i guarantee i
could see something in the pacific ocean
that matches like that full yeah well it
should be cleaned up
it should be cleaned up immediately and
thrown away
extinct
[Music]
[Music]